three days before I asked him about
Shadow Banning Senator Ted Cruz in a
senate hearing about big Tech and
censorship asked him about uh what
Twitter is doing related to the New York
Post and the hunter Biden laptop and
Shadow Banning and much more ability is
you have the power to force a media out
and let's be clear the New York Post
isn't just some random guy tweeting the
New York Post has the fourth highest
circulation of any newspaper in America
the New York Post is up 200 years old
the New York Post was founded by
Alexander Hamilton and your position is
that that you can sit in Silicon Valley
and demand of the media
that you can tell them what stories they
can publish and you can tell the
American people what reporting they can
hear is that right
no this was this was a you know every
person every account uh every uh
organization that signs up to Twitter
agrees to a terms of service in terms of
service so media Outlets must genuflect
and obey your dictates if they wish to
be able to communicate with readers is
that right
no not at all we you know we we
recognize an error in this policy and
specifically the enforcement you're
still blocking their opponents you're
still blocking their post right now
today you're blocking their posts we're
not blocking the post anyone can tweet
and the New York Post uh post on their
on the Twitter account if they go into
their account no is your answer to that
no unless they forget to reflect and
agree with your dictates anyone can
tweets thank you consider the New York
Post sensor Politico presumably you can
censor the New York Times or any other
media Outlet Mr Dorsey who the hell
elected you and put you in charge of
what the media are allowed to report and
what the American people are allowed to
hear and why do you persist in behaving
as a democratic Super PAC
silencing views to the contrary of your
political beliefs
good work there Ted Cruz
I'll get you a beer next time I see you
yeah so that is three days before I then
again asked Jack if they Shadow ban he
says no and he the thing is the guy was
obviously lying the entire time Ted Cruz
knew he was lying he said we recognized
an error
he's talking about the hunter Biden
laptop and how they censored the story
that they've recognized an error except
it wasn't an error it was clearly by
Design they had teams of people that it
was their job to do just this to fill
out these tickets make sure certain
things didn't show up in search make
sure things couldn't Trend and that
people couldn't tweet certain things or
DM them
etc etc so he lied I think that that
it's possible that he could be in
trouble because he probably lied under
oath to Ted Cruz whether he lies to me
on Twitter is irrelevant but lying to a
senator under oath about what whether
you Shadow Banner or not and again I
think he'll get a good lawyer and the
good lawyer will just they'll just get
so lost in the word Shadow band sort of
like Bill Clinton uh what's the
definition of is is right